[Music]
if you're booting up Skyrim
special-edition expecting to be
overwhelmed by a transcendent visual
splendor you're much more likely to be
disappointed than blown away Skyrim's
visual upgrade is noticeable but by no
means incredible and many of its uglier
elements like it's off-putting character
models persist but here's the thing
that's totally ok the ps4 and Xbox one
versions visuals are now on par with the
game PC players have been enjoying for
years the brighter colors and crisper
textures make the experience more
immersive than ever for console owners
where previously for example enemies in
the dark might momentarily blend into
their blurry or muddy backgrounds
lighting and textures are now improved
to a point where visual sloppiness no
longer impacts gameplay patek and that's
the key Skyrim is without a question or
caveat one of the greatest RPGs ever
made the fact that console gamers can
now enjoy the experience even more is a
direct result of the remasters visual
updates a positive turn of events yes
it's somewhat disappointing that even
this updated version of Skyrim can't
match modern graphics but the game looks
objectively better as if a blurry gray
filter has suddenly been lifted and the
new visuals allow for an even deeper
appreciation of Skyrim's rich leveling
multifaceted combat vast open-world and
deep well of side content it was as big
as the mountain in blackest night
it's right over the barrel dragons now
is it please mother if you keep on like
this everyone in town will think you're
crazy that appreciation is further
deepened by another crucial improvement
shorter loading times previously ducking
into a shop or entering a dungeon would
trigger an impressively long loading
screen but now these same instances pass
in maybe a quarter of the time given how
frequently you encounter loading screens
in Skyrim that's actually a more
meaningful improvement than the upgraded
graphics Skyrim's infamous glitches seem
to have subsided as well at least to
some degree I did notice some characters
clipping through objects and my
companion randomly spawned at the bottom
of a cliff when I walked out of a
particular dungeon but I didn't
encounter any floating mammoths or
broken objectives in my companion when
he wasn't busy spawning in a weird place
did a decent job of staying out of the
way during comment
admittedly my time with the game thus
far has been brief I've played roughly
six hours on PlayStation 4 which is a
drop in the bucket compared to 150 hours
I spent on the original Skyrim on PC
there's still a chance however I'll
encounter more bugs as I progress
further into the game on the flip side I
also need to explore Skyrim's three
major DLC packs which are included in
the special edition as well as the
healthy collection of mods already
approved and available for console
players if you somehow miss Skyrim when
it originally launched five years ago
you owe it to yourself to play the game
and special edition is unquestionably
your new best option to do that and if
you did play Skyrim you now have a valid
excuse to return to Tamriel's snowy
northern region and complete all those
guild missions you missed the core game
feels just as engrossing and
exhilarating now as it did back in 2011
frankly the only players who don't stand
to gain anything from Special Edition
are PC players who've been consistently
modding and playing the game for the
past five years if that's not you Skyrim
special edition is an easy
recommendation
you